love thy neighbor as thyself
easy to say
but very hard to do if we were in high
school I'd take him behind the gym and
beat the hell out of them we can do our
best
to seek a life of light and Hope
and love Donald Trump and the Maggie
Republicans represented extremism that
threatens the very foundations of our
Republic
and yes truth
truth you're okay you're not gonna
you're not gonna get coveted if you have
these vaccinations I get accused of
being an inveterate
optimist
for unvaccinated we are looking at a
winner of severe illness and death for
unvaccinated those are the words of
kajal katanji drowned Jackson
our Supreme Court Justice
[Applause]